I'm going to begin with something a bit
pedestrian but we're still we what
people are still bucking this up and
it's just going to get worse in the
future if you take this approach with
other kinds of questions this is a proof
here given the left hand side and a
right hand side you must start from one
side or the other and get all the way
through the other side right if you need
to employ some other techniques where
you manipulate both sides in order to
try and help you see what's going on
that's fine but to prove you should go
from what together and you certainly
certainly certainly should not start
with that as your first line that's like
kind of putting a gun to your head and
pulling the trigger in terms of proof
okay so let's have a go at this now
which is why I'm raising you remember we
had a look at trig identities right you
guys enemies and we said to prove one
side equals another usually the way we
start is with the more complicated side
and you simplify simplify simplify until
you reach the simple side ok I don't
know I don't have a direct answer this
may be one of you can tell me after I
finish explaining why this is the case
my brain actually tends with these
questions to go in reverse and I'll show
you what let's how to start with the
left hand side this is where I'm going
to begin and what I want to think about
is what should I apply to this in order
to get it closer to the right hand side
and the right hand side gives you some
big flashing clues namely these guys
right there is a change of base taking
place so automatically you know I have
to do something to change that base
right away nothing else I do matters
until that is done so what i did was i
thought okay i can express this all in
terms of base too that's easy right just
the standard change of pace law which is
these are the top so it's going to stay
on the top log base 2 of x the six is on
the bottom so it's going to stay on the
bottom log base 2 of 6 okay this is a
fantastic there because you can see I've
already got my numerator in place
already got my new ready place
now to move from here to here I admit
and this is how the designer question
the one kind of spins people out of it
they're like where on earth can i
possibly get that one now being that
this is what I've got at the moment it
clearly must come from a law it must
come from a long somewhere that gets
simplified into what right think about
reviews change of baseball what's the
log law that converts these into 1 1 is
equal to log base a of a right to raise
something right to whatever power to get
itself that's not behaving so therefore
he are bit I've just converted
everything to base to these guys are
based to I'm expecting a log base two of
two somewhere there how do I get it so I
want to suggest yeah Doris yep fantastic
2 times 3 there you go I agree now by
the way this is a show question so even
though this step here is it seemed
relatively trio I think it's valuable I
put it in my solution as you can see if
you're all looking at it once you've got
this then you can convert it to two logs
right the product becomes a son so
you've got that log base 2 of X don't go
straight to the one you've been given
that it's a one so you can't use that as
part of your argument right that's gotta
be where you finish so I'm going to go
to here instead okay may not mean a
difference but if the difference between
trying to show that the burden of proof
is on you right now I'm just using what
you've got the question without
understanding it and now I can state the
right hand side okay as required does
that make sense
any questions okay so like I said little
things most people work sort of head in
the right direction but they missed some
minor points it's a look in this guy
some ways going in the opposite
direction okay you've got to start with
this that's all you know okay so i'm
just going to write that down okay now
help me out what Loblaw am I going to
use to combine this to get closer while
I'm required to prove it fantastic so
just like the opposite of what I did
here you can see different log was are
being tested hey Bala if you're having a
conversation that's great I'm confident
looking at the conversations that you're
happy I think they're good conversations
Rajon see exactly if you kind of have
your conversation in the way that's
quite enough so that you can still pay
attention to not disturb others then do
not have it wet at all times per day
okay I don't mind you having a
conversation if you can't have it quite
enough to actually hear what's going
around and around you but evidently is
troubling this is the product rule in a
sense this is the question hi sir as
means to suggest that you've got the
fraction there and now that i have have
everything in terms of one log i can get
from a log equation to an additional
equation right an exponential has a work
so what if I got here what am I going to
have as the subject will give it subject
to at the base to the act by and that's
where you can see this coming up right
of course over here I've got that and
now algebra takes over you've done the
blog part the mud parts out of the way
all you need to do is make why the
subject it's not difficult right this is
going to be 2x minus 2 to the X Y I've
just multiplied the one by this way
across there's my 1 plus y there and now
I just need to gather my wise and gather
my ex's right so let's see I'm going to
I'll add a line that Olaf's so I'm going
to have 2 to the X take away the one and
i'll have to to the XY plus y that ok so
i just have my order matching up nicely
this is already the way that I need it
over here I just need to factor out
right so there's that soon of it sorry
there's that why bring out the front and
that means I'm only one step away from
making why the subject right and I'll do
that all at once you're doing it now
just a footnote before answer your
question this feels really important
don't pull any punches on this when we
move further into the HSE course and we
meet a topical inverse functions right
this manipulation of like sort of going
from this being the subject of this
being the subject it's a critical skill
critical